alexis est une de mes activités dans la
vie c'est de préparer les étudiants qui
passent des entretiens d'admission en
gros ils ont des écrits et ensuite ils
ont des entretiens oraux et moi je les
récupère j'essaye de les faire passer de
l'autre côté et une des choses qui
stresse le plus évidemment mais les
petits coach et c'est la question du
stress la question de l'anxiété
alors évidemment ils vont passer devant
un jury qui veut le juger avec des gros
yeux
ils ont peur et moi qui suis déjà passé
par là ce que j'essaie de faire c'est
que j'essaie de leur donner deux trois
clés de compréhension pour mieux employé
donc c'était l'anxiété
alors moi il m'est tombé dessus comme la
misère sur le pauvre monde un jour
j'avais rien demandé à personne
j'ai vu des version soft comme face aux
entretiens par exemple et puis j'ai eu
des versions qui pique un peu plus donc
c'était simplement pour vous dire c'est
de là que ça vient et l'anxiété alors la
peur l'angoissé peu importe comme on
l'appelle c'est une émotion qui est très
désagréable que vous connaissez tout ce
qui peut être franchement destructrices
dans certains cas mais qui est toujours
bon goût d'être utile et si on apprend à
l'écouté si on apprend à en faire
quelque chose
l'anxiété peut devenir un formidable
catalyseur dans ma vie et c'est ça dont
j'ai envie de vous parler ce jour vous
parler c'est comment l'angoissent comme
moi j'ai combattu comme un forcené au
début a fini par devenir le meilleur
professeur que j'aurais pu imaginer
et j'aimerais a traversé a évoqué deux
trois petits sujets psychologico
philosophico humain que j'ai trouvé sur
mon chemin à travers ça il repassa je
suis mort de trouille je sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte
non mais sérieusement de pythagore en
fait j'ai des organes dans mon corps je
savais pas qu'il existait et c'est le
rater sinon moi je passe vous déjà pris
la parole en public mais j'imagine que
vous avez déjà attendu dans un couloir
pour un entretien entretien d'embauché
ou attendiez les résultats d'un test ou
pas vous êtes décidé un jour aller
parler à cette jolie fille holly garçons
vous plaît bien que vous avez de coeur
qui se met à taper vous êtes dans un
état pas possible et en fait c'est très
utile et pourquoi pas ce que ça vous
sauve la vie en face à un mammouth ça
vous sauver la vie alors le mammouth
c'est un animal qui tue pas forcément
toujours très conciliant et s'il a
décidé de s'en prendre à vous il va se
passer la chose suivante soit vous allez
vous battre
soit mais à mon avis c'est ce qui se
passe la plupart du temps vous allez
courir très vite et du coup votre corps
il cesse et donc ils s'adaptent donc dès
qu'il ya un danger potentiel
le coeur se met à taper la respiration
devient super profonde
vous mettez à transpirer parce qu'il
faut fournir la machine etc c'est
mécanique très bien huilé évidemment
vous avez une grosse boule dans
l'estomac sinon c'est pas drôle c'est
votre corps qui vous dit tu dis jara
tomberg heures plus tard et on devrait
on devrait être content d'avoir ces
trucs-là manche en attendant moi ya pas
de mahmoud ce soir et je suis quand même
mort de trouille
la première chose que m'a appris mon
anxiété c'est le lien entre la pensée et
l'émotion j'ai mis du temps à comprendre
qu'en fait une émotion ne venait jamais
d'un événement extérieur est bien
toujours de l'interprétation qu'on a
dans la tête l'autre jour mon ami adrien
viennent boire n'était pas très content
parce que il devait dîner avec une amie
qui l'a planté au dernier moment j'avais
une heure et demie de retard
j'ai dit pourquoi t'es pas content il
écoute une heure et demie de retard
c'est un manque de respect bon donc
juste pour ça que t'es pas content je
dis imagine la chose suivante imagine
que tu avais un travail monstrueux avant
pour demain et que dit manquait
justement une heure et demie pour finir
ton taf
elle s'appelle jeudi j'ai une heure et
demie de retard comment est-ce que tu
réagis je suis soulagé quoi ai je dit
regarde comment une même données
extérieures même événement extérieur
peut provoquer de réactions
émotionnelles complètement différente
alors évidemment qu'on peut dire que
l'événement extérieur a une influence
sur nous bien sûr rien aux hammams outre
bien sûr mais si vous regardez bien
l'émotion n'est pas créés par
l'événement extérieur s'il est
catastrophique elle est toujours créé
par l'interprétation vous en faites dans
notre tête est ce que c'est le mammouth
qui vous fait peur ou est ce que c'est
la possibilité qu'ils vont mettre un
coup est ce que c'est le vide qui vous
fait peur quand vous montez la tour
eiffel même s'il ya des vitres ou est ce
que c'est la projection l'éventualité
que
c'est ont réussi c'est invraisemblable
je sais ce que c'est vous qui me fait
peur ce soir ou est ce que c'est la
possibilité que mme et à bafouiller que
je me vois tu devrais vous au passage
que je raconte là n'est absolument pas
nouveau je veux dire marc aurèle déjà il
ya deux mille ans disait si tu es en
peine à cause d'une chose extérieure ce
n'est pas cette chose qui te trouble
c'est le jugement que tu portes dessus
et d'ailleurs jeudi marc aurèle j'aurais
pu dire glandier j'aurais pu dire jésus
j'aurais pu dire les modistes montaigne
qui vous voulez donc je fais que
réinventer l'eau tiède
donc ça c'est le premier truc que mon
anxiété m'a appris et que j'essaye de
transmettre à mes petits coach et c'est
que le noeud c'est la tête
vous me direz battant deux secondes si
on a une réaction émotionnelle à chaque
fois qu'on avait pensé on n'est pas
sorti du bois
est-ce qu'on a une réaction émotionnelle
à chaque fois qu'une pensée une traverse
non et heureusement d'ailleurs
vous imaginez un petit badge aussi je me
dis et si la foudre me frapper là
maintenant logiquement je devrais avoir
peur
je n'ai pas peur je m'en contrefous
pourquoi parce que je ne crois pas à
cette pensée c'est à dire que je pense
qu'il ya un paratonnerre tout à fait
compétent surtout à l'université ça
m'affecte pas vous imaginez un petit peu
ce qui se passerait si à chaque fois
qu'on avait une pensée
on avait une réaction mais selon
vivraient dans un chaos émotionnel
sombre j'avoue marcher tranquillement
dans la rue comme ça qui d'un coup vous
dites arrêt si je me faisais cambriolé
ce soir en flèche s'il y avait des
aliens qui débarquait et elle sait ce
qui se passe avec les plus anxieux quand
on fait une crise d'angoissé ça qui vous
arrive la raison est souvent très
stupide simplement et ils ont cru les
angoisses et ça n'existe pas c'est
simplement des gens qui sont pas
conscients de ce mécanisme n'est qu' à
chaque fois que je pense est
complètement est insignifiante leurs
travers sa tête ils se prennent les
mécanismes bien voir ce que je dis là
pour l'anxiété ça marche pour toutes les
autres notions positives ou négatives
qui rouvre la colère la jeannoise il y à
des primes de maintien qu'à des primes
au cdij donc le deuxième truc que j'ai
fini par comprendre avec mon anxiété
c'est que pour qu'une émotions prennent
pied il suffit pas d'avoir une pensée il
faut aussi y croire elle danse elle
vient de là je vous vois venir vous
allez me dire attends de seconde
si on apprenait à mieux maîtriser nos
pensées si on apprenait à croire
certaines pensées et à ne pas croire
d'autres pensées on pourrait se défaire
de toutes les émotions négatives
oui sûr qu'on peut donner envie que ça
va intéresser ses consignes ce que j'ai
appris à travers l'anxiété c'est que on
doit apprendre à observer ses pensées
c'est à dire que si vous observez bien
les pensées qui nous mène sur un
mécanisme complètement inconscient je
dire elles sortent de nulle part
exogènes elle s'associe vous avez des
images des sons des phrases des morceaux
de ceux ci des mélodies des projections
des souvenirs et vous vous rendez bien
compte que vous êtes absolument pas
conscient de ce qui vous passe par la
tête
donc la première étape consiste à
comprendre ce mécanisme
j'ai sur vous avait déjà était assis
dans un bus tranquillement et puis vous
voyez quelqu'un hawaï avec une dame avec
son sac de courses et puis le sac de
courses vous fait penser au dîner que
vous avez la semaine dernière le dîner
de la semaine dernière vous fait penser
au déjeuner le déjeuner vous fait penser
à votre belle-mère et votre belle-mère
vous fait penser au fait que des fois
c'est pas facile quoi et je vous voyez
et puis des fois comme ça vous vous avez
complètement les vagues et puis d'un
coup vous dites ah tiens pourquoi je
pensais à ça que vous remonter le fil de
pensée et vous êtes à et celle là c'est
là je suis parti chez moi ça m'arrive
tous les jours donc la première étape
c'est d'apprendre à devenir consciente
mécanisme
comment on fait très concrètement on
s'assoit on observe alors ce qui tombe
très bien en fait c'est que vous êtes
déjà si je vais pouvoir me livrer à une
petite expérience sur vous alors je vous
demande et la chose suivante juste
détendent et donc je vous promets on en
a établi qu'ils avaient pas de mahmoud
ce soit a priori personne va vous mettre
d'occupation dans les deux prochaines
minutes
d'ailleurs je m'y engage et juste
détendez vous juste pour lâcher vos
muscles mais aussi derrière votre écran
un cynisme à du jeu y compris votre
langue
j'ai pas si vous avez observé la langue
c'est toujours le truc qui se détend en
dernier étendez votre langue pourrait
suivre et concentrez vous sur votre
respiration est tout simplement laisser
vos pensées venir peut-être qu'elle peut
être qu'elles viennent pas peut-être que
vous pensez à votre belle mère justement
peut-être que vous pensez et un éléphant
rose j'en sais rien moi maintenant que
j'ai dit les fonds reçus sûr qu'il ya
certains qui pensent au delirium et si
c'est pas fait maintenant maintenant
c'est fait
vous voyez que c'est un mécanisme en
fait que vous ne contrôlez pas peut-être
que vous via une sensation peut-être que
vous vous dites j'ai faim peut-être que
vous via un jugement peut-être que vous
dites que vous aimez bien la chemise un
ceux qui pensent penser là c'est une
très belle pensée je vous en prie
continuez
merci donc l'idée c'est simplement
d'être présent à soi-même et de voir ce
mécanisme à l'oeuvre c'est à dire que
simplement observé c'est un peu une
démarche de scientifiques si vous voulez
je n'y ai pas de est ce que vous savez
ce que vous êtes en train de faire en
fait de la méditation l'habitation s'est
pas être assez en position du lotus
ça peut aussi l'être ça et c'est pas non
plus un vulgaire exercices de relaxation
pour être plus compétent et plus
productif le jour d'après c'est
simplement laisser être ce qui est vous
vous êtes là si vous faisiez une pensée
très bien vous laissez pas embarquer par
la pensée si vous bien une sensation
très bien vous allez me dire pour
combattre l'anxiété
merci un exercice comme ça c'est assez
chiant quoi je préfère aller manger un
burger soit je vous ferai l'objection
vous pouvez tout à fait méditer en
mangeant un hamburger
la seule chose à faire c'est la passe de
vous laisser embarquer dans vos pensées
pendant que vous le manger avec la
réunion de demain piel cours de ceux-ci
et puis à bastien il faut que je pense à
telle ou telle chose c'est de simplement
être présent à vous même quand vous
mangez le burger c'est ce qui s'appelle
le font appel à la commande il ya là le
présentiel me vient pulmo mais
méditation de pleine conscience et une
des variantes
il ya tout un tas de gens en fait qu'ils
aiment bien faire tout un tas de choses
et du coup à méditer en épluchant les
carottes c'est très bien donc voilà où
ça m'a amené l'anxiété
ça m'a amené à ce point là est ce que
j'ai observé c'est que cet exercice
d'observation de la pensée il a un
bénéfice en ont ils à 1
il ouvre une porte parce que quand vous
observez votre pensée vous dites oh
tiens il me vient 6 et puis tiens on
éléphants roses et puis vous réalisez
bien que vous n'êtes pas votre pensée on
peut pas à la fois être votre pensée
observé autre pensée elle est là et du
coup ce qui se passe c'est que il ya une
distance qui se crée entre les deux et
c'est ça qui est terriblement
intéressant
c'est que si je ne suis pas à penser qu
est ce que je suis je suis l'entité qui
regarde c'est quoi cette entité c'est
que c'est quoi le mois et voilà le
questionnement fondamental qu'on trouve
dans toutes les traditions spirituelles
religieuses philosophiques du monde
entier depuis des millénaires et comme
moi je l'évoqué en trois minutes
alors j'en parle généralement assez peu
à mes étudiants de ça parce que parce
que face à un jury ça les aide pas mais
mais avec vous je me lâche un petit peu
plus est ce que vous avez observé
comment eu la sensation d'être le mois
ne nous vient que de notre pensée
observé ça ça nous paraît logique comme
ça mais ça ne l'est pas tant que ça je
pense donc je suis et il nous a joué un
sale tour descartes c'est un génie un je
dis pas mais d'un point de vue
strictement émotionnel ce type est un
cornichon
je pense donc je dis pourquoi pas je
ressens donc je suis dit pourquoi pas
j'aime donc le suis si on se penche sur
la question
ça nous bien que donne à penser que du
mental vous dire je suis alexis alors
évidemment il ya une dimension physique
corporelle je fais un mètre 87 ce que
vous voulez mais je suis un thème j'ai
grandi dans tel endroit
j'ai fait des études j'étais legouge et
l opinion et en fait ce personnage qui
est construit et qui a une utilité mais
il est 13 c'est très embêtant de tirer
son sentiment de moi de ce personnage là
et c'est ce qu'on fait en permanence de
manière inconsciente
alors on peut tirer ce sentiment de mois
d'un job par exemple vous allez en
soirée la société nous y encourage en
soirée il fait quoi dans la vie
je suis entrepreneur et tout d'un coup
mon - up se fixa dessus et je vis
j'existe d'une certaine manière à
travers ne serait ce que quelques
secondes à travers ce concept
d'entrepreneurs on peut se prendre pour
un titre aussi je me souviens à l'époque
je bosse et on choisit en ambassade et
la secrétaire s'était fait engueuler par
le secrétariat des ambassadeurs parce
qu'elle avait croisé dans un couloir en
disant bonjour monsieur est pas bonjour
monsieur l'ambassadeur
le premier c'est vrai donc voilà celui
là il tirait son mois de son titre était
ambassadeur ça peut venir de plein de
choses à venir d'opinion regardez en
politique c'est très amusant observé
j'ai toujours été en libéral il existe à
travers ça ça peut venir d'un goût
j'adore la can dance qui ça peut venir
d'une chose aussi triviale qu'une sale
habitude
j'ai toujours détesté faire la vaisselle
ou ça peut être une maladie aussi c'est
bien sauf si on s'identifie souvent à ça
j'ai mal ça peut évidemment venir d'une
possession
vous voyez le cac et avec ses sa grosse
voiture ses jantes 17 pouces et sa sono
ou la demoiselle avec ses talons de 12
avec l'écrit louboutin dessus existe à
travers ça qu'on me comprenne bien
j'ai rien contre les talons de 12 je
trouve ça très bien l'été j'aime les
tags 11 12
le problème c'est que ce personnage
qu'on crée autour de ça si on tire notre
sentiment de moi et notre sentiment
d'être de cette chose là les ennuis
commencent
et c'est ce qu'on fait tous en
permanence c'est ce qu'ont fait tous et
inconsciemment et c'est extrêmement
vicieux mais le jour où je me suis rendu
compte que je me sentais existe et je
sentais mon mois en partie à travers mon
statut de motards parce que j'ai une
bécane à lagny ça m'a fait bizarre je me
suis dit en quoi je vaux mieux que le
baraqué dans sa brousse qu'est ce donc
voilà certaines traditions
philosophiques considère cette fausse
conception du mois
commettant l'erreur fondamentale c'est
ce qui s'appelle légaux et disent que
toutes les souffrances humaines viennent
le ce truc là alors toutes les
souffrances humaines je ne sais pas moi
en tout cas il ya un truc que je sais
c'est tout les ans était donnée de ce
truc là est ce que j'avais vraiment peur
il ya 10 minutes tout à l'heure quand
j'ai commencé à parler devant vous ou
est-ce que c'est mon ego qui avait peur
parce que j'avais vraiment un danger
physique ou est ce que j'avais
simplement la trouille de gaufres et de
mango c'est intéressant comme concept
est ce qu'on peut apprendre à être en
dehors de cet ego de ce faux moi je ne
sais pas je cherche encore et comment on
fait pour le faire je ne sais pas la
meilleure pensée qui me vient c'est
celle de la nhtsa del vasto qui était un
disciple de gandhi et qui lie la chose
suivante il est allé chercher dans le
dictionnaire la définition du verbe être
vous ne trouverez pas définition du
verbe être parce qu'il n'y a pas de
définition
m être ces êtres il n'y pas plus que
vous trouverez une définition de l'odeur
des lilas quand vous les définir nous
garder là à les sentir le lilas et vous
saurez l'odeur des livres tels que c'est
pareil pour l'être peut-être qu'il ya
une porte à ouvrir de ce côté là du coup
moi je vous raconte ça comme une sorte
de vieux maître zen je vous rassure tout
de suite je vais rentrer chez moi à
l'heure je vais râler parce que j'aurais
oublié de passer au supermarché et je
vais manger bon burger en mettant les
pieds sur la table
voilà j'ai rien à vous apprendre
simplement je me suis rendu compte d'une
chose à travers mes anxiété en creusant
en apprenant d'elle j'ai fini par me
rendre compte qu'il y avait un monde
entier de réflexion derrière et si vous
apprenez à changer de regard sur vos
anxiétés j'espère que c'est ça qui vous
arrivera aussi c'est tout le mal que je
vous souhaite et je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté